jessica is with us in California hi
Jessica how are you I'm good how are you
Dave better than I deserve how can I
help my husband and I we live in
Southern California and we pay 1500 and
rent a month and my mom has just offered
to let us live with her for a year and a
half to sing for a down payment on a
house and we were just wondering if you
think it would be wise for us to keep
renting after we finished living with my
mom or it's to save for a down payment
or if we should make a down payment on a
house with what we save what's your
household income about sixty thousand
dollars a year right now but it's going
to go up because my husband is an
electrician he's an apprentice and so
every year he makes more until he's a
journeyman okay and okay so if you lived
with her for a year and a half you would
save eighteen thousand and so $27,000
probably more than that because we won't
be paying rent know that is rent that's
fifteen hundred a month for eighteen
months there's 27 thousand okay and
you're gonna save more than that we
assume that we will just because we
aren't really we don't have car payments
we don't have any other debt we have a
small student loan that we're almost
done paying off but besides that we live
on just very little yeah okay well I I'm
fine with you going ahead and buying a
house at that point if that's what
you're asking
on a 15 year fixed with that as a down
payment I'm not sure where in your area
you're going to be buying though yeah
that's going to be challenging with your
income and with only twenty seven
thousand dollars down or thirty thousand
or thirty two thousand or whatever it
ends up being right yeah that's probably
about what we were thinking like 35 yeah
and so if you get that much down as your
down payment and you take a 15-year
fixed-rate mortgage in Orange County
you're probably not in that County are
you we're in Orange County yes no I'm
saying you're probably not buying in
that County well that's where we want to
stay well here but because if we bought
like a condo yeah okay I mean if you can
find something where this the payments
are less than you know they're equal to
or around 1/4 of your take-home pay at
that time whatever his income goes up to
with a $35,000 down payment on a 15-year
fixed then I'm fine with it and you
won't live with her for 18 months and
save all that rent in order to do that
and everybody's good with that he's good
with that you're good with that it you
know you need to be real clear about
your timeframes and exactly what's going
on
and you need to be real clear about
boundaries and you know the process
you're doing you know what kind of
family processes are gonna be going on
during that 18 months and is this
something you guys can do without ending
up being mad at each other when you're
done that kind of stuff you got to
really work that part through but I
assume you have or you wouldn't have
even been this far down the road in the
decision-making so yeah but financially
it sounds like it lines up